j'accueille patrice drevet
[Musique]
salut à tous c'est nouveau ça vient de
sortir le mini journal est un journal
pour les jeunes et les ados c'est la
volonté de vous donner tout simplement
une info plus décontractée un nouveau
rendez vous sur tf1
un peu avant 18 heures les lundis mardis
jeudis et vendredis 10 minutes
d'actualité en trois parties l'info du
jour plus un mini dossier sur un
événement particulier
et enfin tout tout tout ce qui vous
intéresse des fringues à la bande
dessinée en passant par le rock n roll
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
patrice drevet à pézenas dans l'hérault
où il est conseiller municipal pour un
réveil dans les airs
[Musique]
on va aller au club de ma libre on l'a
survolé ces à 500 m d'ici et il ya des
vignes et c'est parti pour une journée
bien chargée
enfin s'ils sont authentiques 4-4-2 bien
démarré du premier coup
alors stéphane chez les vignerons et il
ya 34 ans il est venu me voir en disant
est ce qu'on peut faire un vin qu'on
appellerait la cuvée drevet ben c'est ce
qu'on a fait puis alors ça marche bien
c'est un très beau vin je me trompe à
paris oui ça débute à l'eau
et là il me répond aux vins oui d'abord
mais voir celui là on a déjà vu celui en
avion qui était magnifique et je suis là
et pas mal aussi regarder et oui les
miracles de la météo et merveilles
toujours patrice est d'ailleurs le
monsieur météo à ses informateurs pour
prévoir le temps elle sur les
grenouilles
oui oui quel temps il fera demain
bon bah il va pleuvoir et il commence sa
tournée quotidienne par des artisans de
la région
patrice est très engagé politiquement et
tient donc à l'esa lui l'ouvragé d'écart
au ciment que son grand père fabriquait
qu'il a remis au goût du jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hu donc en fait tu le mets comme ça et
puis c'est bien ça il ya ma première
tesselles pas mal un salut david
toujours fidèles arrivés au marché il
est très en retrait ouais du bruit ou
gardien de sao paulo
enfin très populaire bah ça va très très
mal comment tu vas à l'horizon de byte
huawei aussi impeccable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un maître de ce 6 au piment d'espelette
ou c'est pour demain soir on la fera
cuire la main on va servir à et au
détour d'une ruelle
il a même des supporters
allez
météorologiques pour cet après-midi on
attend quelques gouttes
cet après midi d'été allez un peu de
sérieux il est temps d'aller travailler
direction l'hôtel de ville pour une
réunion municipale la mairie et on va
pouvoir faire notre petite conférence
[Musique]
tous les deux après jean-pierre
là-dessus annonce est pas trompé parce
que j'ai regardé qu'est ce qui est
urgent à faire le plus urgent
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
t
voilà l'idée du mariage si les réunions
[Musique]
voir ma fille au revoir
c'est ça le rythme de ces journées
alliés loisirs et travaille toujours
avec humour et sourire
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière séraline sur
patrice drevet patrice bienvenue sur
plateau tout le monde apparaît merci
alors vous êtes né le 4 janvier 1948 à
paris dans le 14e à 4 heures du matin
alors on note tout de suite une sur
représentation du chiffre 4 et ça s'est
pas arrêté et c'est fou j'avais fait
votre fameux mini journal en 1984 vous
avez travaillé 44 ans dans l'audiovisuel
une histoire formidable c'est un jour
vous dites j'ai joué le 4 aux courses
dans la quatrième il est arrivé numéro
j'ai joué quatre millions sur leucate en
touche alors on fonce sans terre vous
dit papa du livre côté de maman les
heures nécessaires à ma conception
enfance fauché mais heureuse du côté de
saint thois du côté du marché aux puces
votre mère se bat pour élever ses trois
enfants vous épie votre demi frère et
votre demi soeur voilà enfin deux mois
assez difficiles quand même hein ah ben
je suis allé chez le crémier puis
c'était plus facile si c'est moi qui
allait acheter le lait et le sucre et
que je disais j'étais pas plus haut que
trois pommes maman pas sera payé en fin
de mois
alors vous dites à saint-ouen il y avait
les cocos à la mairie il est curé à
l'église et comme c'est le curé qu'il a
trouvé le premier appartement de ma mère
demandait ben voila je me suis retrouvé
au patronage tout à fait c'est vrai et
quelque part je suis très contente de ça
parce que pas mal de mes copains qui
étaient du côté des cocos à la mairie
ont pas tourné comme moi n'ont pas mal
tourné mais disons que ça fait mal le
comme j'avais pas de père à la maison il
y avait une ourse un curé qui faisait 2
mètres de haut
et quand je faisais une connerie ben je
prenais un coup de pied au derrière
voilà j'en faisais par deux alors enfant
de choeur communion solennelle et scout
et scouts de vous laisser votre promesse
de scouts à lourdes c'est un événement
pour vous qui vous a marqué à jamais en
fait assez fascinant parce qu'on remonte
le calvaire de nuit aux flambeaux étape
par étape
c'est resté gravé gravé dans ma mémoire
alors à l'école vous êtes bonheur
assez petit train oui je m'occupais de
l'animation va vous retrouver dans un
pensionnat de père polonais oui c'était
comme un oui sous comme un polonais je
suis témoin ouais à oui je suis témoin
mais on était tranquille comme ça le
soir au dortoir complètement
cela dit j'en garde un souvenir
extraordinaire c'est un prof de latin
qui m'a donné l'envi 2d mais le français
est de jouer avec les mots et ça je les
gardais tout toute ma carrière
alors finalement vous retrouver à
l'école du spectacle rue du cardinal
lemoine vous rencontrez d'ailleurs
patrick dewaere qui est là-bas en même
temps que vous vous appreniez quoi alors
on apprenait soi-disant la culture
générale pendant quatre heures
l'après-midi et le matin on pouvait
vaquer aux répétitions pouvait le soir
joué dans des pièces de théâtre et moi
je faisais de la musique à l'époque je
tapais sur une sur une batterie j'avais
un groupe de rock qui s'appelait les les
oui sont passés dans les fêtes foraines
donc un soir je finissais à la batterie
alors fin 1964 encore un 4 1 4
vous avez 16 ans il vous devenez
assistant de pierre laforest sur une
nouvelle chaîne qui s'appelle la
deuxième chaîne de télévision vous
l'avez connu comment pierre laforest
tout simplement parce qu'il est venu
recruter des figurants à l'école du
spectacle
j'ai été désigné et puis je suis passé
dans la première émission alors j'étais
fasciné j'ai demandé l'autorisation de
revenir la semaine d'après pour le
prochain enregistrement
ils m'ont dit ok pour voir tu vois comme
ça que j'ai tapé l'incrusté y avait une
bière à aller chercher
on me on me donnait un peu de monnaie
puis j'y allais et puis après je suis
monté en grade j'avais le droit les
chercher les sandwichs et ça s'est
terminé par le fait que j'organisais les
auditions va de serge lama de françois
zahoui et vous finissez responsable
d'édition du 20 heures quand murray est
avec roger gicquel donc j'étais le
patron en régie quand on était trop long
c'est moi qui prenaient l'initiative de
supprimer un sujet où l'autre au
téléphone avec avec le présentateur bien
évidemment alors en mixant sont cuites
comme beaucoup de vos collègues vous
êtes mis à l'écart de la télévision et
vous vous retrouvez serveurs dans les
voitures restaurants des wagons lits
oui bah oui fallait et dans une voiture
et ce temps c'est pour mieux te regarde
ça aussi un souvenir j'ai fait du film
après dans ces voitures j'ai réalisé des
documentaires c'est la belle époque
c'étaient les voitures bleues tous
montés frey et il y avait des clients
assez riche d'ailleurs qui choisissent l
horaire de leur train en fonction du nom
du chef de cuisine dans l'orient express
à face était le la compagnie
internationale des wagons-lits vous
retournez ensuite travaillé la
télévision de 1969 jusqu'en 84 vous
réalisez dans le monde entier des
interviews de stars pour le journal
télévisé alors j'étais au service
culture de la rédaction de tf1 alors que
ça ouvre les portes
j'ai lié d amitié avec la femme de
marley qui m'appelait pour ja il a
photographié à central park à new york
par un truc de ouf alors bowie mccartney
mick jagger et yoko ono frank frazetta
pas dans les toilettes il aimait pas
bien les journalistes
en fait pour me venger je dis ça serait
marrant de caen face on interviewe dans
les toilettes avec le look et tout ça et
je les interviewés dans les toilettes de
chez q quelle grande salle entre 10
mercury qui m'a draguée à mais bon
et jake scully c'est pas mal hein saint
georges que des parce que l'un à côté de
l'autre qui est ce qu'un faussaire de
l'autre alors printemps 1984 encore 1,4
évidemment vous présentez presse-citron
oui c'est un magazine pour ados et là
antoine de caunes vous propose de venir
le rejoindre sur canal+
mais vous préférez faire le mini journal
le fameux mini journal tous les jours
sur tf1 à 18 ans traîne m'appelle en me
disant tu vas voir on va s'éclater la
nouvelle chaîne on va on va faire ce
qu'on veut c'est extraordinaire fut dit
oui je viens et je vais voir mon
directeur de l'information lui dit je
m'en vais là il me regarde droit dans
les yeux et me dit non tu es le dixième
à partir c'est par été le meilleur mais
il faut pas augmenter mais qu'est-ce que
je peux faire 20 turin jeudi barrière
petite tranche de 10 minutes qui
appartient à l'information
personne ne s'en sert moi je j'aimerais
bien il ya du dessin animé
tu me la donne et je fais un petit
journal télévisé décalé il est court on
l'appelle le mini journal
et là il s'est passé un truc fou c'est
que les adolescents ont regardé le
journal c'est à dire quoi je pensais pas
le faire pour les jeunes ce sont eux qui
se sont approprié le mini journal
c'était quand même regarder à 50% par
des adultes alors le samedi avec minimag
aussi quelle émission culte
de l'époque à une anecdote que j'adore
c'est un jour donc il n'y a pas
d'oreillettes le sujet n'est pas prêt et
le réalisateur vous dit le sujet pas
prêt rajoute quelques phrases de temps
que ça arrive comme il me dit ça en
direct au téléphone je dis oui maman oui
maman toute excuse moi maman oui bien
sûr on va en parler mais excuse moi
maman parce que là je suis en train de
travailler
je suis en direct je te rappelle plus
tard un moment sans voir je t'embrasse
et je raccroche 1 et le lendemain des
tas de messages de gens plus vous êtes
un fils formidable en plein travail vous
répondez à votre maman
c'est vrai que c'était il ya eu un
retour fabuleux et b beaucoup de
courriers non vraiment alors à l'époque
on veut très très star évidemment
quelles ont été les réactions de votre
entourage
ma mère elle était fière voile en
parlait partout son fils à la télé votre
père biologique n'a pas cherché à vous
retrouver entre elles il sait même pas
qu'il m'a fabriqué d'accord puis quand
les gens dans la rue ils me disent vous
en avez pas marre qu'on vous reconnaisse
dans la rue moi je réponds toujours vous
savez moi mon père m'a pas reconnu à
l'armée autres me reconnaissent ça me
fait vraiment plaisir faux vos relations
avec les médias à l'époque c'était quoi
alors il y avait deux choses j'étais le
chouchou parce que c'est un peu
l'émission que tous les journalistes
rêvé de faire je faisais tout ce que je
voulais je voyais mon directeur de
l'information deux fois par an et
deuxième chose très importante pour moi
c'est que j'étais un petit peu le
l'école du journalisme de télévision
beaucoup de jeunes sont passés par mini
journal pourquoi parce que quand il
allait voir le directeur de
l'information utile est pas fait des
essais fait donc un reportage pour le
ménage on a eu plein de journalistes qui
ont pour la plupart réussi et qui sont
passés par l'école mini journal et ça
j'en suis très fier alors vous avez
gagné de l'argent à l'époque
non c'était mini-journal mini salaires
c'est là où je me suis fait un petit peu
mais c'est pas grave sur le plan
amoureux ça vous a apporté de nombreuses
conquêtes
non mais j'ai toujours pensé que c'était
pas c'était pas ça c'est pas parce que
tu es connu que tu fais plus de
conquêtes qu'un autre jeu mais ça a été
quand même un assuré le minimum syndical
oui c'était quoi le meilleur moment de
cette époque c'était d'aider des petits
moments comme ça où je recevais james
blonde sur mon plateau puis venaient
s'asseoir à ma place mini journal des
trucs comme ça c'était c'était fascinant
pour moins fascinant et le pire moment
le pire moment
ou tu vas pleurer dans l'est dans les
toilettes c'est quand tu apprends compte
à supprimer l'émission parce que tu un
bétonneur qui arrive qui sait pas trop
ce que c'est que cette évasion
et voilà je me suis un tout petit peu
vengé 1 au moment du 7 d'or j'ai fait
balancer une dernière justement en
octobre 1987 vous recevez un 7 d'or pour
le mini journal et le minimag du mag et
le problème c'est qu'en fait vous venez
de démissionner un mois plus tôt quoi et
je balance je tiens à remercier le
président que téva retour
jeudi l'ancien parce que nouveau c'est
lui tout à remercier la mais pourquoi
ils ont viré cette émission mais parce
qu'ils ont mis un feuilleton américain
la place qui coûtait 10 fois moins cher
ça coûte cher un thé un journal télévisé
c'était un vrai journal télévisé un pour
les jeunes là vous partie de tf1 et sur
l'a3 fait génies en herbe ensuite sur la
deux et en 1996 on vous confie la météo
ce qui me plaisait c'est qu'on attendait
pas là non on vous dit que c'est plus
difficile de faire la météo en direct
que d'interviewer david bowie à broadway
jeudi même plus que ça je dis que c'est
plus difficile que de présenter le
journal de 20h quand vous êtes en direct
avec william leymergie télématin que
vous avez prévu trois minutes de
bulletins qui vous dit à aucun n'étant
tahri torres 20 secondes mais que 10 10
secondes avant que ne commencent les
bulletins en plus à la gestuelle
parce que derrière il a rien en fait
c'est un fonds alors il ya un fond vert
ou à fond bleu et puis tu as le retour
dans leur tour tu es à l'envers tant que
ça part dans tous les sens et il faut
pas trop se mettre devant la température
de la corse
ça ne peut pas de faire rigoler pita les
bretons aussi on n'est pas simple et que
je sais c'est qu'en même temps la météo
11 ans et en suisse est parti je suis
parti en 2008
ça faisait longtemps que je faisais la
météo n'avait jamais fait aussi
longtemps
quelque chose en télé alors le maire de
pézenas me dit patrice tu veux pas venir
sur ma liste
et comme j'avais organisé un festival de
films sur les métiers à pézenas qui
marchait très bien j'avais été un petit
peu à deux parties voilà je suis parti
là-bas je suis parti et je me suis
arrivé
arrêté à france 2 fin janvier début
février je partais en campagne
électorale pour l'amérique petacchi ont
agréé aux dernières élections et effet
444 c'était aux régionales évidemment si
j'ai fait le paris dakar en k4 oui
obligatoirement 80 ans + 6 6 et 6 4
mais je défends dans un parking et reste
une place et celle à 40 et quelque chose
est ce que vous êtes nostalgique de
l'époque du
non je suis pas nostalgique non je
m'interdis d'être nostalgique j'aime
bien jouer les anciens combattants quand
je revois les copains et 15 juin que les
commandes on a pu faire un bien
évidemment je suis pas d'installer si
c'était à refaire votre vie qu'est-ce
que vous ne referiez papara et patrice
alors je ne cesserai pas les cours
d'anglais
ah oui parce que interviewé david bowie
à broadway en ayant un anglais
approximatif je me débrouille et dans la
ville je me débrouille mais après quand
ça rentre dans le technique et
heureusement david bowie avait à
l'époque une costumière belge qui était
donc trilinguisme et qui a servi un
petit peu sur des moments difficiles
mais quand je lui dis ma dernière
question je dis à david bowie comme ça
are you the last rockstar là ils me
regardent avec un grand sens sur l'a31
règle dans le jeu vous allez mourir que
sur les cons remarques sur votre tombe
suivez la flèche merci patrice est très
heureux de rallumer la lumière soit et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou